bachelor nation reacts to bachelor in
paradise returning after production on
the reality shows fourth season was shut
down in Mexico earlier this month
in an exclusive statement to ET on
Tuesday VIP vet and season four cast
member Vinny ven teairra revealed he's
excited to quote get back to the beach
he also shared this photo holding a
sledgehammer on Instagram joking it's
time to get hammered again
iggy rodriguez from rachel lindsay
season of The Bachelorette also told ET
he would be thrilled to take part again
Raven gates took to Instagram to share
her excitement with this sultry snap in
a bikini captioning the pic see you on
the beach
Chris Harrison tweeted his thanks to
bachelor nation for their quote patience
trust and loyalty e t--'s lauren zima
sat down with Robbie Hayes after it was
announced the hit ABC spin-off will
continue filming it's crazy I didn't
think there's a chance we come back I
mean I thought with everything that went
on the morality of it and the name of it
might have been tainted a little bit but
Warner Brothers released a pretty Stern
statement and all the cities over these
are Stern's so I'm excited would you
return to paradise I have to see I don't
know the timeline you know I had
scheduled some things now that I was
back in the States some stuff with leave
your let ik's this comes after Warner
Brothers released a statement on Tuesday
revealing their internal investigation
into allegations of misconduct on set of
bachelor in paradise is over they added
there is no evidence to support any
misconduct by a cast member or that the
safety of the reality stars was quote
ever in jeopardy production on the
fourth season is scheduled to resume
[Music]
you